"Укрзалізниця" не хоче підвищувати вартість квитків, проте хоче надати пасажирам сервіс кращої якості.
У цьому їй має допомогти німецька Deutsche Bаhn. Меморандум про співробітництво між Укрзалізницею та Deutsche Bahn уклали ще в 2020 році.
А у серпні цього року підписали перший договір з однією з фірм німецького концерну - DB Ingeneering.
З середини вересня німецькі фахівці проаналізують стан речей в секторі пасажирських перевезень "Укрзалізниці".
Відповідно до угоди, "УЗ" сплатить за консалтинг DB приблизно 900 000 євро.
Очікується, що орієнтовно за півроку німецькі фахівці представлять свої перші рецепти успіху для "Укрзалізниці".
Не менше 40% пасажирських вагонів "УЗ" є або застарілими або зношеними, із завершеним терміном експлуатації.
Відповідно до умов договору, фахівці DB ingeneering мають розробити нові технічні умови закупівель пасажирських вагонів.
Зокрема, для нічних потягів, а також приміських електричок.
Більшість нинішніх вагонів розроблялись ще у радянські часи і не передбачають багатьох сучасних зручностей.
Приміром, немає сучасної системи кондиціонування та USB-розеток.
Вагони не обладнані зручностями для маленьких пасажирів та їхніх матусь-татусів, зокрема, столиків для сповивання чи-то відповідної білизни.
Не враховані потреби пасажирів з обмеженими можливостями.
Годі й казати про якість сидінь та спальних місць.
Якщо затвердять сучасні технічні умови закупівель пасажирських вагонів, участь у тендерах зможуть брати іноземні компанії.
Ми хочемо одразу зробити такі вимоги, які б ідповідали  сучасному стану наших підрядників –
виробників рухомого складу і не тільки національних, а і європейських, світових лідерів…
На виході ми отримуємо такі технічні вимоги, за якими світові компанії, будь то Альстон, Сіменс чи наші виробники, зможуть брати участь,
але ми будемо гарантувати максимальний комфорт і сервіс для наших пасажирів.
Наразі в Україні є потяги дальнього сполучення, поїзди приміського сполучення та швидкісні ескпреси.
За останні 10 років схему маршруту потягів суттєво змінили.
Кількість маршрутів зменшили в середньому по областях на 30%, змінили також частоту рейсів.
"Укрзалізниця" хоче врахувати скарги пасажирів щодо дефіциту потягів на певних маршрутах
та розрахувати логістику перевезень на цих напрямках.
Фахівці DB мають допомогти  розробити 5-річний план розвитку компанії -
прорахувати кількість потенційних пасажирів, нових маршрутів, вагонів та потягів.
Вони також підрахують обсяг необхідних капітальних інвестицій з боку держави.
В цьому році держава, вперше за багато років, зробила велике замовлення для "Укрзалізниці".
"Крюківський вагонобудівний завод" на Полтавщині виготовить 100 вагонів, які мають бути поставлені до кінця 2022 року.
Також виділені кошти на електрифікацію залізничних шляхів у Центральній Україні.
Проте, за попередніми прогнозами "УЗ", цих вкладень може бути замало, враховуючи перспективи найближчих 5 років.
"УЗ" не хоче і не може фінансово відповідати за все - за сервіс, якість перевезень, стан вагонів, кількість маршрутів.
Підприємство обирає нову бізнес-модель, за якої ділить відповідальність із державною владою і частково місцевими органами влади.
Фактично держава або місцеві органи влади формують замовлення залізниці на певні маршрути і беруть участь в їхньому фінансуванні.
Можливо, разом затверджують тарифи на ці перевезення.
Не виключена й участь приватних компаній, яким необхідні певні маршрути, приміром, електричок.
В такому разі "Укрзалізниця" може гарантувати, що зможе перевозити пасажирів, не збільшуючи ціни на квитки до реального рівня.
Адже, за даними компанії, вже наразі реальна вартість перевезень  є мінімум на 20% дорожчою вказаної вартості у квитках.
Аби підготуватися до цієї моделі , ми залучимо німецьких консультантів, які розрахують нам приблизно мережу за такими перевезеннями,
вартість, розрахують той обсяг компенсації, який ми могли запропонувати компенсувати нашим партнерам - замовникам
і фактично підготувати проєкти договорів - драфтів, які б ми з місцевими і центральними органами влади органами влади могли б укладати.
Пілотний проєкт, який продемонструє ефективність такої моделі управління та фінансування перевезень,
можливо, цього року запустять в Запоріжжі та Дніпрі.
Кошти для участі в таких проєктах, на думку експертів "УЗ", могли б виділити місцеві органи влади, які б стали замовниками послуг на перевезення.
Адже в результаті реформи децентралізації їм поступово переходить в управління й транспортна інфраструктура.
Крім того, є і кошти на такі проєкти, оскільки тепер до 60% податкових надходжень залишається в місцевих бюджетах.
Розробка нового бізнес-плану "Укрзалізниці" має торкнутися і можливостей запровадження дедалі більших програм лояльності для пасажирів.
Зокрема, появи сервісу знижок постійним клієнтам, меншої вартості квитка,
якщо його придбали заздалегідь і оновленню вокзального простору.
Пасажирам першого класу або пасажирам потягів підвищеного комфорту "УЗ" хоче запропонувати аналогічний сервіс,
як для пасажирів  Бориспільського експресу - з окремою лаунж-зоною для очікування та відпочинку,
більше електронних сервісів та мобільних застосунків.
Розглядається поява якісних фудкортів у приміщеннях вокзалів та загалом покращення вокзального сервісу.
Улітку президент Володимир Зеленський оголосив про те, що "Укрзалізниця" є банкрутом.
Рада нацбезпеки та оборони ініціювала введення тимчасового керівництва "УЗ",
пояснюючи це "критичним станом підприємства" і загрозами для нацбезпеки.
"Укрзалізниця" має великі очікування щодо результатів співпраці з DB.
Вже у січні мають бути оголошені перші результати фактично аудиту УЗ та попередній бізнес-план на п'ять років.
До цього часу і "УЗ", і "Дойче Бан" мають розробити також формат їхньої співпраці у майбутньому.
Зокрема, розглядається варіант залучення німецьких топ-менеджерів для роботи в "УЗ" на посадах,
які відповідають за управління, планування, організацію маршрутів, закупівлі, роботу з клієнтами.
"Укрзалізниця" запевняє, що в Україні, попри значний скепсис, можлива європейська якість залізничних перевезень.
Також в "УЗ" наполягають, що така співпраця з німцями не веде до участі "Дойче Бану" в приватизації компанії,
яка на сьогодні залишається на 100% державною.